We talked about a whole bunch of things
that we think should be private.
We should be able to exercise control
over who can learn about them and
who can use that information.
But there are other things
that are clearly not private.
For example, where I live, my address.
You buy a house,
there's some that's recorded,
the deed is recorded, and
by your local government or whoever.
And anyone can go see that
book where that's done.
Am I registered to vote in the US?
This information is public.
You don't have the right to say,
it shouldn't be collected or
shared with anyone else.
And some more surprising
things may not be public.
I, as a professor at Georgia Tech,
which is a public university,
my salary is public because
the state of Georgia said so.
Actually, this is a good point.
The context is extremely
important as well.
So, we talked about communication,
emails.
Well, as the employees of the state of
Georgia, we're subject to, Georgia Tech
is subject to, it's a public university,
subject to open records requests.
The other side of privacy we're
going to see is your ability
to access information,
so privacy limits it.
So, there is certainly sort of
trade-off, and what you and
I view as private.
Some things are clearly private versus
non-private, but obviously in other
cases, we may have different
opinions and those opinions may have
been formed by who we are, our cultural
backgrounds, and things like that.